le coût de la vie c'est l'enjeu qui
préoccupe le plus les canadiens selon
les sondages particulièrement les
familles et c'est d'autant plus
perceptible en banlieue de toronto
[Musique]
ici on est devant une station-service de
burlington en ontario il ya ces
autocollants qui ont été apposées sur
les pompes par le gouvernement
provincial on peut voir le coût de la
taxe carbone par litre il n'y a aucune
mention qui est fait du remboursement
pour les citoyens par contre tout est
fait pour qu'on montre d'ailleurs c'est
écrit que ça va coûter cher à
l'environnement comme money back labsolu
toronto c'est peut-être la clé de cette
élection ce sont des circonscriptions
très nombreuses qui souvent vote en bloc
ici on peut gagner ou perdre le pouvoir
on est devant une agence immobilière là
qui fait des ventes du côté de
burlington on va aller voir un peu quels
sont les prix du logement ici alors ici
on a une annonce pour un petit condo une
seule chambre à coucher 385 milles
dollars
et puis ici on a un appartement encore
une fois d'une chambre à coucher 480
mille dollars
s'ils ont des budgets entre 5 à 7 900
mille dollars et peuvent absolument
trouver moi je pensais plutôt laid mais
les jeunes familles au moins 5 700 mille
dollars
malheureusement c'est ce qu'ils doivent
il ya quand même hein
des ventes qui se fond dans ce prix là
mais dès qu'on regarde si c'était des
jeunes jeunes couples sans enfants qui
ont des budgets à moins de 500 milles
alors là ça devient très difficile à
trouver et comment il faut alors comment
vous quand vous retrouvez face à des
familles qui comme on commence à ce mal
heureusement sinon pas le budget alors
ils doivent continuer de louer pendant
qu'ils puissent
économiser de l'argent la maison très
cher les loyers sont très cher leur
malheureusement s'apprend très longtemps
pour économiser le dmp me on est ici
devant une école francophone catholique
les compressions en éducation c'est un
sujet qui revient souvent dans nos
discussions avec les gens ici le
gouvernement ford a déçu même certains
électeurs conservateurs n'est pas
l'essai défendre jusque l plus avec le
plus d'argent qu'elles n'en ont fait
beaucoup de levée de fonds
un campus qu'on en avait il ya quelques
années puis je pense que tu as causé par
des contraintes budgétaires en milieu de
la santé soutient m je dois croquer oui
moi je travaille dans une les hôpitaux
je prédis autres puis quand
vraiment des miracles avec très peu ça
c'est nouveau de l'année qui semblait
puis gouvernement